for joining us I'm Alondra Nelson like
the Dean of social science here at
Columbia University and I'm delighted to
welcome you all to this event Europe's
moment of truth organized by the
European Institute and our cooperation
with the Maison Frances we are extremely
honored to have with us first vice
president of the european union
commission vice president franz
timmermans who will discuss with us the
current challenging to challenges facing
Europe today by the president timenado
is particularly what a place to tell us
about europe as i discern any of you
know he has been the right-hand man of
jean-claude Juncker the President of the
European Commission for almost a year
now and we've seen that it's going to
particularly hectic year so I don't in
the work I've take him for it mr.
Tibbals joined the Commission after a
very distinguished diplomatic and
political career throughout which she
was constantly involved in the life and
destiny of Europe as a diplomat as an
advisor to be you and the oh
commissioners as a number of dutch
parliament as the dutch minister of
european affairs and as the dutch boy
minister mr. vice president thank you
for being here with us today we're quite
honored by the presence deeply so we
very much look forward to hearing your
thoughts about the challenges facing
Europe today at a time that you recently
described as a moment of truth in
European history which brings us here
I'm also delighted to introduce my new
colleague our great steal from Yale
professor attitude who is the Catherine
and Shelby Colin Davis professor of
history at Columbia and the new director
of the European Institute having
succeeded Victoria to Grazia 50 here no
it was the more collegiate professor of
history and he succeeded or the summer
professor choose will moderate the
discussion and the question and answer
session with the audience you should
know that this event is also a special
occasion for Columbia as it marks the
opening of a new series of conferences
entitled getting to know Europe series
at the European Institute which receives
generous support from the EU as well as
other donors the next event in this
series is tomorrow evening and will
feature among others Nobel Prize
laureate for Hancock and a discussion of
the European dream I will now give the
floor over to Professor tubes who will
introduce the discussion but before that
please join me in welcoming vice
president temerity
thank you so much it is an enormous
pleasure to be here as you like tech
signal log of university first vice
president's day and he's so much for
taking the time to be with us you will
discover over the course of our
conversation that it's not just
authorities it's a real pleasure first
vice-president image is extremely good
value so we are going to have a million
so you see I have no doubt oh we've
already started an intense conversation
over lunch and I'm certain that the
audience here is going to want to have
you where your question current as
variety the range of issues facing
Europe today is whether it's an
extraordinary time to be at the helm
there as you said a sort of how to glue
your darkest moment this may be the last
chance Commission this is a commission
which is really not to get things right
before we go there boy open the floor to
questions we I should also say we need
to wrap things up with the last question
around 20 20 25 35 us too because first
much president Timmons a schedule is as
you can imagine intensely busy so you'll
forgive me if I'm a draft and severe
about that line but I think before we
plunge into that that discussion of the
the present day allow me to indulge my
my tendency as it is story to go back in
there was a way of escaping the present
but there's a way of getting back to the
presence of my different round and if we
go back over your career after a
childhood brought up besides as a hero
graft on the move
add your time in Rome a multilingual
education which we will benefit which
should we benefit from enormously after
national service you entered me in Dutch
civil services of pollen service officer
and end up being posted quite quickly to
Russia and my understanding is that you
witnessed the fall of communism the end
of the Soviet Union from the desk in the
Dutch finals and I know this is
something that stay with you refer to it
several times can you tell us a little
bit about how that shaped your your
earlier post alley ah detect superior
well you see I've always maintained that
the mix challenge for my generation
would be how we cook with the end of
your time I was brought up as training
the soldier to be an interrogator I
learn Russian in the army because we
still believe in those days yes young
people is true then we will go to or
with potentially with the Soviet Union
and I was trained to to interrogate
partial powa prisoners medics food yes
absolutely I mean completely nonsensical
of course we've been destroyed within
few minutes but that was the attitude
that was my younger years that was the
age of animals yes you you have today
and to go from that to a situation where
the wall comes down where European
defiant and stops that is I was
said the most important event in my life
and I want wanted to dedicate my
professional life manage consequence to
make sure that we could handle that we
can integrate Central and Eastern Europe
into the European project that we could
offer the people they are wanted freedom
openness transparency all the things
that have lacked during communist or
prep oppression and i think frankly
looking back now with all the mistakes
that were made and all the problems that
arose it is a sec tabulous a spectacular
success of historic proportions and i
believe we should be proud of that that
we are as Europeans but the last couple
years I started to wonder whether that
was really the biggest challenge I would
face in my in my
it's time to be seen at all because
global developments because of social
restructuring going on the Western world
that might be the police this don't as a
challenge we faced and as you move from
the source service into politics by way
of the Labour Party bastions of social
democracy you the solution presumably is
social democracy welfare and more Europe
this is the way it is get to work and
then all of us were this disposition
faces shattering shop in 2005 when two
of the knee elephants of that article
slaughter Leslie in elephants of that
original European project in 2005 vote
down the constitution that is in fact
going to complete this perpetually
unfinished business of building a
political year and in the interview your
cabin interview with the FT you describe
the the shot this man fuel system and
then you respond to the way and
charmingly any Dutch politician county
does which is to get on your bike and
ride around your constituents it and
take a coffee with your constituents
which is a reaction working
hopeful and out of this you say came to
muse of Europe few new premises the
evaluating its its ideas can you tell us
a little bit more about that vision
which I think still informs your sense
of what European politest ought to be
about it vs. 2005 inception I think for
me and bursting the biggest change me
one step to to challenge the premise
that Europe needs to be constructed at
the expense of the nation state that we
can only do the European things by
taking them away from the nation-state I
think that comes with frog I think
you're totally constructed with the
nation-states nation-states needs we
reinvigorate their sovereignty needs to
be reinvented and be charged as a verb
through Europe and that is the vision I
I now have a European cooperation which
is why he challenged me as many people
argue that national sovereignty can only
be restored by taking things away from
Europe and actually they're making
exactly the same mistake as we used to
make in thinking that you could only
construct your for the expense of the
nation-state they're now making the half
are saying you can only save our
countries at the expense of European
integration which i think is just wrong
as the opposite side this is my first my
specific a tournament is widely regarded
as the EU secret weapon in the struggle
over Greta because because of this this
this distinctive take on on the on the
on the situation that we're in
sort of the Chief Inspector Clouseau
your accent is far too much more natural
that out because the honor or a far more
serious note in in 2012 you move into
government an hour in the regular
foreign minister and facing them as it
were the situation in Europe and the
other half the most acute phase of the
eurozone crisis and then in 2013 the
disaster European power policy in the
Ukraine the derailment of Europe's
negotiations with the UK and the ensuing
revolution there and the escalation of
violence there and without point you're
engaged relatively normal diplomacy if
you can carry making the Netherlands
contribution to the EU starts against
Russia it must be the subject to seem
quite remote until that terrible day in
July 2014 when the news comes through
the wires of the shooting down and the
lady airliner which claimed 290 lives of
which 200 work were was 204 dodge and it
puts you in this extraordinary position
of having to articulate the
the grief and anger in your country must
have felt at that moment then in some
ways comparable to 911 its intensity for
a country the size of the Netherlands
it's a total shock and you you go to the
Security Council invited to the Security
Council a lot of the Australians to to
address the Security Council and if you
haven't seen the speech that first place
better than timmermans made on education
I really strongly urge you to do so
because it's an example I think of a
democratic rhetoric applied to the truly
extraordinary humanist retro but tell us
how to bad experience is you express
their sense of grief of justice and also
rebound frustration of the inability of
the international community to get to
grips with this problem which have led
to this murderous mass assassination
those horrible certain spices how did
that change of you international affairs
and does that stay with you still as a
defining moment change my life obviously
as I did of all the relatives and
friends of the people
the application it has changed it is it
is all the point that international
politics you know is not our additional
something that can affect any national
community for any day and it also
convinced me of the need to reinforce
international cooperation make sure
United Nations connect these occasions
to not see international instruments as
outdated we need to be future and I also
think me then as Europeans got it wrong
with Russia 20 years some of us being
completely obsessed with Russia are
being terribly naive but surely because
of that because of different attitudes
whenever I'm able to formulate your in
policy towards Russia root and was still
not be good fast to put it mildly so all
these things play a role there my most
important points at the time when
Security Council was it I needed to get
Security Council to endorse our efforts
to have access to the region to make
sure we could bring the victim's home to
make sure we could invest
to make sure that we could lay the
foundation prosecution is wrong and we
need an international community for that
that was my goal going to the Security
Council and I as profound need to tell
these mothers and fathers around the
table because they're not just people
representing their countries that also
mothers of the table now need to explain
to them what was going on the mic how
this was perceived by the nationwide
elation was greenlit what was happening
and I really wanted to make it very
explicit and thats related it is as I
said something that you should see you
haven't had the chance to it's credited
I think returning the Security Council
and the usuals policy of more assertive
sanction certainly adjourn context that
is the defining moment I think in
pushing Merkel and the judge business or
anything else out of its position as
naughty significant Peter that same
summer earlier euro is going through the
routine of earlier in parliamentary
election and the business of selecting a
commission and it goes about it in a new
way and sense that the parties in the
European Parliament for the first time
nominate pits and covered up to the
first line Dominic leads candidates and
there's an understanding tacit it turns
out as explicit it might have been that
the candidates use rupees Marty wins the
educate elections will be the first
paper presents younger images and it's
younger in turn who canvases the
government's and out of this process you
emerged as the Dutch commissioner
as a lot of the same was selected by
your courtesies his right hand magnus
this new position of the first vice
president so the commission is now
structured into commission as vice
presidents and timmermans is the first
vice president working directly for you
occur in a kind of CEO or almost in
managing the business of commission it
is later to you which is published
online which describes his mission
statement one of the recurring refrains
and one of the things that's also
retrieving and puzzling is this demand
that this be a political commission but
this is not a technocratic organisation
this is a political commission article
to the Parliament and what I really want
to ask is what that means what does a
political commission it's made up of
people from across the political
spectrum you direct you run for this
focus so how do we imagine there sir and
does it is it part of an ongoing
transformation of the new constitutional
itself understand first of all means
that the local preparation which
very interested in everything I've never
been interviewed by anyone is so I have
believed in the idea of specie kinda I
thought it was a political game I I
thought it would bring anything I
thought the end of the day in the
european council will decide anybody cry
while it was i wrong was wrong on this
massive evil the fact that they chose
Ashley gave jean-claude juncker a
position that is more independent from
the national governments for the
European Council that any of his
predecessors before so political
Commission means that President the
Commission who has the room to be more
political than his predecessors because
he could say no to big member states
with measure course but still too much
larger degree than his predecessors
because he got his mandate in the quotes
with European Parliament's and of course
you know the european council endorses
but it wasn't their choice that has a
huge little effect on the relationship
between the institutions and so the
Commission is now thanks John Krueger in
a position to be more independent and
when he says its last chance Commission
it is a commission that is more
independent and therefore tries to be
the Commission as intended is the treaty
which is normal secretary-general of the
European Council nervously
epub so we need to ascertain our old
position and need to say no sometimes a
ten say no to the European Parliament
give you hugs I wish Seto oh we're not
used to that anymore so both European
Council and your department have to get
used to as do over the Commission and
Franklin Commission selves it uses that
role and I see it as my duty to to sort
of help commission structure is get your
spectral because no the Commission is
traditionally and has become of the
earth long or a huge collection of
silence silos that shall ever meet and
do the business for the decider and with
a new structure with vice presidents you
know we're breaking down and that is
creating much more political momentum at
a much earlier step we discuss policy
across different policy areas at a much
earlier stage than just below before and
that's creates all this Momentum's well
this is the famous meeting when 280
proposal to pack it down to 23
active Star Chamber to to move on to
policy we need more speeches what struck
by are occurring a frame and I think
it's very fascinating one for anyone
interested in democracy democratic
politics and the retro at the Democratic
leadership it's it's it's a fascinating
you're playing in this issue of cell
called repeatedly said the fundamental
threat to Europe or the proximate
obstacle it needs to overcome as a lack
of self-confidence and the end gaming
suspicion mutual suspicion between
Europe incidents in outer that's earth
of the one hand the new credibly
resonant created it's a phrase with a
history America to graduate high waisted
increase felt and we have nothing to
fear the fear itself democracy needs to
mobilize itself crashing now it was also
potentially kind of painting it's a
phrase which could mean nothing to all
other than a kind of positive thinking
and the sunniness i took my familiar
much of europe nevertheless it could
just be that so so what for you was it
we've got some more self-confident to
paraphrase montwain announcement of our
minds is the premature
Europe has a lot to offer to the world
we have I think highest educated
population across the floor and out of
the world we have the strongest and best
social systems of the world we have the
filthiest best educated youngest
generation of the world we had many
things going for us but we go to see in
like that we think you know we were
wearing sort of an end of days which i
think is totally unjustified I'm happy
to change that by stations even if I
great features that will not change so
we need the end of the summer at a time
when people don't want to involve i buy
it and I think this is one of the
challenges I was talking to to refer to
them as NGOs but there's a different CSO
was last night civil society
organizations and they were asking us to
do all sorts of things and building a
situation and I was saved them which it
didn't
we have to say cover artist agencies are
very narrow no no big ceeze always have
narrow consistency across population and
where we are taking down silence the
Commission I see in European society
sila was emerging all over the place in
society I can take very personal example
my oldest daughter she's 28 she is a
pharmacist assistant my oldest son he's
26 is a lawyer they lived in different
worlds literally in different worlds
they're worried about different things
my son where is our global problems my
daughter where is powered machine read
my head and this is the same generation
two people who love each other dearly
would do anything for each other but
sometimes Dalton understand each other's
weldon this is happening in younger
generations or rust West grow especially
in Europe don't they don't share get
together it glowed system we're all on
the same but there's this adhesive many
people out there who don't understand
that commitment to the rest of all
because they have different workers and
that's where my where I believe we're
social democracy by can input is dying
is because we're no longer building
bridges we're returning to a situation
where politics will be formulated as
politics serving one specific interest
and that how you do that in a complex
democratic society I don't see if I
don't see it working so we need to get
together with people in social
networks with people in in civil society
to make sure that we start developing
the concept of building bridges between
people with different interests and
creative coalition it's based on shared
interest whereas a shared interest in a
society where is it can we formulated
across social boundaries across ethnic
boundaries across age boundaries can we
formulate something that we have in
common that is where the future lies and
democratic politics I'm not sure where
well equipped to get what we need to do
we not one more question in an open
floor and it follows in a sense it's a
kind of echo of what you just said but
it is a puzzle to me in frustration we
already started to look about revelation
which is that for a politician who
espouses this language of self
confidence and optimism the search for
the creation of me community on the one
issue that i would have thought the
dearest of the heart of european social
democrat the problem of unemployment
well president yonkers referred to 40
mins 29th nation the european you 29th
nation of the unemployed that's in
youngish young people whose lives are
being ruined by larger the after effects
the current crisis which which they were
largely not responsible too young to be
responsible the debt
but in the face of this the response by
the European nation states and indeed
the Commission is so anemic the level of
the ECB how something like you before
that they were the structural reform is
endless good intentions and lots of
talked about to leave early mid-late
mark the single missing ingredient that
Americans take the Arctic namely a
powerful fiscal responses face evident
demand failure which is clearly the
state of the eurozone right now the
response to that is this 300 billion
euro vestment prob am from the
Commission which turns out basically to
be a kind of leverage right of Finance
scheme which may or may not displaced by
the activity as you were saying much
depends on the initiative reproduction
of entrepreneurs to come forward which
is the situation of depression and
lacking self-confidence it's not there
it's famously pushing on a piece of
string the dog is dead it won't run the
initiative has to come from the public
side and that to me is really the
prominent question I have for the yoga
tradition how is it that you will get
why not problem where is the confidence
you take healing question to a whole but
you're absolutely right you're
absolutely right youth unemployment is
up my generation is example we lost part
of my generation in the early nineteen
eighties setting the same problem so
much talent was lost in Europe in those
years because people leaving University
to get a job and they never caught on
and we run that this in a terrible way
now which is mind-boggling if you look
at the data on a large scale industry
many member states it's facing the issue
of not having enough people to do jobs
and at the same time we have
unemployment the problem is not that
there's not no jobs and people or an
important problem is that people who are
unemployed on our way able to fill the
jobs that are out there that's the
fundamental problem in place and it's
appropriate education and the end of the
day and I'll say the Commission to solve
all this because we have no content a
very key mission can do things that are
younger models the end of the day if we
don't break out in the moment that
government is bad sites can run
themselves people should pay for their
own education if you don't challenge
that private
which has been so the price in the last
20 years of our governments were run in
in Western societies if we don't
challenge that if you don't bring more
public funds to education if we don't
create the system and lifelong learning
you don't create that sort of a circular
economy of learning people go into jobs
they come to back to education go to up
if you don't do that in Western we will
not create a certain common we will not
be socially sustainable we will lose at
least one generation and we will lose
the competition to the future so i think
i think you you're absolutely right
we're not we're not doing the right
things now i'm not sure that your
premise that we should be investing more
in this or that is the only answer this
i think the lack of confidence in the
capability of government to organize
these things is what's ailing us the
lack of confidence that education can
deliver as a mass challenging the fact
that education is a global public good
it's a national public good challenging
the fact that it's in the interests of
all sizes put money into education and
this should be done only by the ones who
profit from education this is the sort
of thing sort of the bait we should be
having and this is where I see the
future social democracy is it has a
future it's that area that yes yes and
to an extent of the problems of Europe
simply a complete list on
the agricultural simple relationship and
the greater issue is what extent are the
problems of Europe many many nation of
the 29 stationary come from the museum
person the united states federal
structure as a model for you and
christmas rescinded in the euro and the
arrows fiscal policy is Manhattan
attorney to germany as friends and your
POV meet in brussels but it really
hasn't been governor manage the
responsibility to me
member states so people who are going to
for instance the case of usefulness
returning to the drachma of the way of
addressing their lack of synchronization
more importantly medicines i evoke
yesterday and on the m4 in the tenants
and just one of many weakens perhaps one
that stands out because and remember ago
sake how does that suggest what was it
exactly discreet ascaso condition they
were so let's not get into the thesaurus
it's very poor memory and is it right
into the kitchen and it's a problem
because of course you've got other in
front before
when it fixes to a deeper need for
dissemination of the European pocket as
something is natural with your
multicultural member see it now that's
your question that they try and answer
your question if I understand correctly
the issue is that since orders between
nation states in Europe our own resource
of frets the necessity for nation states
to repress diversity within their
borders as large diminished so nation
states because of European integration
become extremely relaxed about cultural
differences within the boards the Dutch
language was suppressed for generations
in the north of France because France
saw it as a threat to its territorial
integrity now Dutch language is
flourishing in his local touch times for
to the north France of you think that
was very interesting say have a good
German and ISA France say happy to
increase their languages in many many
nations and so I would see the pro
process of regionalization as a product
of European integration it's not a
contradiction with you
because no flu the creation of
nation-states was done at the expense of
diversity within the borders of
inflation states in a tremendous way
Frances the case in point maybe some
people died in so-called religious wars
would you not always wanted to spoil
religions and instruments to create
national unity and this happen all
across Europe and in 30 minutes Grace's
to take that problem away leads to new
problem which is the strike strike for
independence regions to see the Belgian
season in the United Kingdom you season
it in Spain and interestingly enough all
these sub-national entities regional
entities have one desiring come to be a
full-fledged member / European project
they are extremely fabulous because they
believe the European Union is the answer
for them to what they've seen as the
rest nation-state so I hope that's
that's good no that's not an answer to
your question I see it in your body the
computer I'm afraid that will have to do
here up hello kumusta chooses example by
asking leading questions the Commission
is University that's where you get any
questions transitioning from a
technocratic paradox or political longer
serving a shortage of political issues
for into a tissue and one of those is
guarding member states ability or
willingness to uphold the standards of
constitutional democracy yes I'm
wondering how much latitude you see
Commission is having in addressing
situations where member states in danger
European Union's commitment to articles
of values democracy human rocks
hungry dhoni the hungries by no means
the only effective let's be very clear
about its white problem that affects
almost all members days but the answer
is not political rhetoric the biggest
failing to do and populist politicians
is to answer that populism with your
populism it only increased and sports
they can drink for their own so we have
legal instruments to be very precise to
analyze goals of propositions to gain by
our comments and to stick to the example
of hungry so far if we really get into
the heart of the matter and are very
precise on the legal instruments we can
correct that every time they will give
in to work with every time until now
once we say no here you be cross the
line you should do is it comeback having
said that is one thing we cannot really
do anything about if member states not
willing to address that amongst
themselves now that is the political
climate that is creative but always
going to extreme or what it's about in a
certain political context and cut it
already
according to creating this image of a
self-destructive Western is willing to
give up its own culture by importing
endless amounts of Muslims and colored
people etc etc that rhetoric is
poisonous but the Commission cannot
counter that rhetoric with the
instruments of our proposal at our
disposal if that rhetoric is not mess by
an answer of all motor states involved
the tendency of member states after the
failure of addressing the situation in
Australian Haider when it was trying to
sort of isolate Austria for entering
into creating a coalition between the
Christian Democrats and the FBO at the
time was very strong reaction buying
some political leaders in France and
Germany it completely backfired because
they didn't know how to sustain her
effort since then countries have become
extremely reluctant to take up the issue
a they hold the Commission will so they
don't have to but that's that's not
possible Commission we can do we are the
enforcer of European rules that we
should take that role more seriously
than we've done that past I will make
sure we do but it's looking very precise
entering into a battle rhetorics that
people like this aura is always going to
strengthen this position you can only be
tackled in terms of political rhetoric
by his peers in the European Council
that's where it happens that's where
he's most of you actually
pasta so your appearance
rather be
a quickly escalating series of crises
which seems a trial was corporation
and my question is as a
how can you stay ahead of the curve in
identifying key issues and notes run
after dunya cycle which forces national
governments
especially one as you said there's a
whole range of challenges
what sort of leverage
compression previous roles for mr. see
yourselves on
tiger
well thats sake just one example the
refugee crisis without basing all the
proposals that were agreed our
commission
all the proposals challenger also
commissioned closes probably took a huge
risk we didn't go to my mistakes goes
nuts understand okay
no step the distribution key with
something member states some mistakes
it's like that we made an analysis of
how we can solve this issue of one of my
mistake saying you take care of your
problems i go to look away this to do
going on for years how do you get out of
that situation we thought about it long
and hard dealing concrete response to
that would be show solidarity and the
only way of doing that is in crisis
situations have a distribution key so
that people you know better run together
solidarity never done before we do this
we got away with it because people
understand you know my interaction
always what it was criticized give me an
alternative that's better another
defendant nobody gave an alternative so
it's the quality of the people we have
in our position which is really outside
really outside if you have a essay to
the studio
with triple a sort of service come away
finish that are really very good quality
of our proposals the diplomacy we pry in
talking to my mistakes about this the
balance we see between the different
interest because the one was had an
interest in not being left with all the
refugees only in their country and the
other side an interest in making sure
that countries were people arriving by
the rules which have been doing for a
long time create a balance and the data
proposals to achieve oh of course and it
might work so now we're now in the best
position on that then we were before but
make no mistake this problem will not go
away will be a long-term issue for
Europe and Europe to understand that it
is no rule of them a continent of origin
but it's becoming a continent of
destination like their own States and
others that psychological change this
past was the biggest challenge we face
and certainly in Central and East
European countries who during Soviet
occupation were told that everybody from
the outside is direct threat to national
identity national stock
yes
how to employ people
and I had proposed training military who
i think i think the refugees or perhaps
the most motivated people who are
looking
so I think by training them Adam
very troops and pointing together over
there is perhaps the best job because
you don't have enough jobs for your
hands what I'm going to do a million
more people well first of all thank you
for your email which was interesting
I honestly that there is no military
solution I honestly believe that putting
troops in that theater will exacerbate
problems will not solve I honestly
believe we need negotiations involved
with all parties need negotiations
quickly we need to get everybody
involved because it is also a proxy war
as you know in the conflict around
around the table that's what needs to be
done virtually having said that I also
believe and I met some of the refugees
soon refugees in the island of costs
that we should be doing much much more
to help parents provide for their
children where they are now in refugee
camps Jordan Lebanon Turkey with most of
them don't even live attacks but they're
not allowed to work so you mean people
in costs I said Jaime
children my crown listen hey I ran out
of all my savings no much over to starve
inter parenting kind of jobs i can feed
them so it's trying to hit John swimmin
turkey let's try and create
possibilities that's that's why you know
we've pledged 500 million i hope you two
get up to 2 1,000,000 to make sure that
in the region we create school greatest
housing preferences for jobs then you
can sustainably have three million
people with 1 billion euro 3 million
people were had to save the future now
and there will be much easier to replace
back to Syria once the conflict is
ending because what's happening now is
the most horrible brain training new
industry because everybody knew it was
part of what was a middle-income nation
a sled that nature so so we have we are
all self-interest we go what we can't
have all these people in your basilica
if we would under those all refugees not
just hope i right or refugees social
systems in Europe put its evolving and
the extreme right we'll come to power in
every single area including German so
that's the thing we need to employ it
and so we have to be honest and say we
count
refugees but we can do much more and as
much cheaper even if it costs beta 2 j's
decent living standards for them in the
surrounding areas and having said that
we also have to be very clear the
countries in the region I've done a
tremendous m Lebanon now has important
its population increased with refugees
equality humans matter how many people
nomination turkey is expecting at least
six billion euros a year on the refugees
Jordan is a tremendous job me I'm not
saying these countries should be doing
why I'm saying Europe should be doing
more but not by inviting people all to
come to Europe that would not serve them
and it was certain create a huge huge
problem in Europe questioning every
country I'm going to take a look there's
very question going back to your I think
paper description more political
permission and talkative of already
asking how can you by step and decide
what my projects and so on we don't just
criticize taught real things my question
would be how do you communicate in the
bridge of this night here with
permission
these good things
just like to see yourself here we go I'm
Dutch now they found to you and
enormously proud of everything that
Jesus to you and I fingers can use
potential but I feel embarrassed and
this point about a lady is dealing with
some main issues at this time and it's
sometimes it looks like there's no
long-term strategy for issues and I'm to
this name if you like Ukraine refugees
Libya shared EU energy policy and
fingers couple more what is your
perspective on that and those are these
issues too complex don't have the
resources or is it immediately to
communication just let me see you
strategy they're essentially the same
question first of all be frank about the
complexity of the problems people accept
your frankness people are loosely fed up
with simplistic solutions but we're in a
situation where my complex answer if it
is not believable r it doesn't have any
perspective and the simplistic solution
many people say ok the complex answer is
not working who knows a simplistic one
night let's follow that audition that's
the situation we're in that's why the
extreme rightist on the right
so all issues in magic energy refugees
unemployment the problem is a lack of
perspective what is the point we're
heading to and how do you communicate
that by not treating people like
simpletons the temptation in politics
for too long now has been to make things
not just uncomplicated in language but
simple in contact that is from your
language has to be uncomplicated but if
you try and convince people that there
are simple solutions to complex problems
you're in the middle of the minefield of
populism you need to get out there very
quickly if you really want people to
support you in a row in the northern
part people will accept the problems of
refugees today they will make way for
them they will create places for them in
Europe unless they have the idea many
have today that we have no clue how to
solve this and it's only going to get
worse once we can create incredible
perspective of how we can get come to
terms with the issue how we can provide
some of the solutions people will accept
the point that it's going to be in a
couple years before we get out of the
problems but if people have the idea
that we're going to know you know where
were talking about fire prevention at
the same time I house is burning down
and I'm going to fire you and I'm going
to trust you and that's the situation
we're in
issues in Europe now and please accept
my point that the traditional Commission
reaction to this is okay let's explain
it again and what is now also going to
work I hope the comparison is you know
phenomenal you speak something doesn't
speak your language and you're trying to
make a point and what you do when you
see the people listen understand the
person doesn't understand me the first
reaction is to speak louder it doesn't
make a difference if people don't if
you're not on the same page people don't
understand where you're coming from if
you're in a different I mentioned you
can scream as much as you like who will
not understand you and certainly will
not trust you we are in why is is is
anti systemic politics on the rise
everywhere because people don't trust
government and more people don't trust
politicians people don't trust system to
deliver the results we've seen periods
of anti systemic quality or but always
with an alternative system in the
proposition this is the first time in my
living memory that were now at an anti
systemics without a proposition of an
alternative that goes beyond I'll take
you to the past which was so glorious
which witch is which is sort of the
typical populists reaction of someone
who doesn't have a good time
two more neither bundled sweater
positions in perspective copies
ok
wrong
violence within yourself now actually a
cool solution
within your amazing
okay that's it breakfast commissioners
there to help scariest words very
carefully we're we're waiting for the
British government to be very precise on
what they want out of the process and
then we're there to try and accommodate
what the discovery would want many
things they want i want the Christmas we
want Europe to concentrate on the issues
we want less red tape falls for
medium-sized enterprises we want to make
sure that the internal market reversals
better we want to have the opportunity
we want an energy Union the United
Kingdom wants all of that so we could
work around then of course there are
changes they wanted a treaty Melissa to
that will try and advise them to do not
I will try and find a constitution at
the end of the day David Cameron will
have to make up his mind whether what he
didn't even see it aggressively this
colyton with us is something he wants to
take the bridge hotel with a clear
position that they should stay in the
area but in subsequent rich people is
two referendums not so to speak to the
side and we will arrive by result of
trying to price Waring hash from the
position from my personal position that
i believe is absolutely the users in the
UK on board I'm even so I am arrogant to
say that is later did you case it was to
say in the EU but hey they will have to
they will have to decide for themselves
and the one question I would ask anyone
and ask our eyes others are you not sure
are you quite sure that by leaving you
you'll be better off that we're saying
are you confident enough to take that
proposition to your photos in good
conscience can we make a good assessment
of the consequences of reps that's my
own question I think it's a fair
question on the other issue well frankly
that's on the new home already now from
inside the system workers in such a way
that people who get asylum in one member
state get the right to resign in that
member state don't get the right to
reside in other words if that all right
to travel to other member states but
they can design another member states
that they can't take a job so that will
be exactly the same situation of the
distribution key you get the right to
reside for five years in a specific
member state and now this is done
because you arrive at a mistake we
register that member state then it will
be done because you will be distributed
to that member state but the principle
is exactly the same you get the right to
reside and work in one member state that
rights does not keep the right to do the
sailing in another member state but you
can travel to the other
see because you've been bigger printed
upon Michael the other member state can
check whether you have a right to resign
so I think that's a way that people will
then perhaps the sphere in illegal
structures hey that's of all times and
quite often that you know very well that
this nation has issue that work remains
for me to serve it is to ask everyone
here to join me in thanking you very
fascinating
can't leave without saying and I say it
also has a former professor at
university I can't leave without saying
that universities need to be more aware
of their responsibilities to other
communities they serve universities need
to be more involved even in the United
States will get much better at this than
we argue is rethinking the way our
society is structured being part of that
process being more actively involved
with practitioners of politics local
regional national level there is a lack
of dynamic there is a lack of
cross-fertilization here that needs to
be addressed very quickly because you
guys are going to shape the future and
you might do it well i did move badly
but you will be doing it thank you very
much